foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody it's me your friendly
neighborhood black person welcome to
Black History Month uh and to
commemorate it we are having a black man
beyond and also because Kevin is off
doing Kevin [__]
um so it's me I'm here Sans Kev but I do
have a friend who is coming along to
play with me for the next hour
um and she's the best she's been here
before you all know her and love her but
we'll we'll get to the gloriousness that
is Tiffany Smith a little bit
um and then we're going to talk about
last of us and we're going to talk about
the raft of things that James gonna
announced that DC is doing but first we
got to pay some bills and so the way
we're gonna pay bills this week is from
our good Folks at nativedeodorant.com so
right now if you want to play along go
to nativedeo.com Fatman and then you can
use the promo code fat minute checkout
to get a suite 20 off your first order
um what would you be ordering you ask
well when it comes to Valentine's Day I
am all about that sweet candy I'm all
about your twixes I need Reese's Peanut
Butter Cups and your ring pops and your
big league chews uh and that's why I'm
loving native's new Limited Edition
Candy Shop collection I call native
products they are thoughtfully
formulated to keep me and you feeling
and smelling deliciously fresh all day
long you know they have their aluminum
free deodorant uh they keep their
ingredients less bare naked with
ingredients you can understand like
coconut oil and Shea butter and baking
soda and they check a lot of boxes 72
hour odor protection naturally derived
ingredients in a smooth residue-free
application they also offer a variety of
scents with new and limited edition
since being released all the time like
the candy shop collection I got gummy
bears strawberry and vanilla Taffy which
I have on right now sour Berry melt belt
sour Berry belt that's hard to say but
hey
whether you want to smell sweet or spicy
and woodsy or clean and fresh native has
a scent option for everyone so Now's the
Time to make the switch from an
antiperspirant to Native when you visit
their site you can discover all their
fresh scents and maybe even try out one
of their body washes while you're at it
I've also got rainbow sprinkle and I
smell like a cookie which is the best so
right now go to nativedeo.com Fatman or
use the promo code fat man at checkout
to get a sweet 20 off your first order
that's
nativedeo.com Fatman or use a promo code
Fatman at checkout for 20 off your first
order and as always we thank the good
Folks at Native for being a sponsor of
your friendly neighborhood podcast which
is us whether we're in your neighborhood
or not so thank you native thank you
native
welcome my friends
um we are going to talk today about a
couple of things but before I do so I
want to welcome
um the wise and wonderful the Great and
Powerful
um Tiffany Smith uh on to this here
podcast hi activities
I feel like I'm coming in this is all my
power excellent
beings from the universe hey
hello
how are you this is totally not an ad
but I love native deodorant see
excellent
you know this is the perfect perfect
episode for me to be honest I mean if we
knew I'd have had you on the ad read and
you could have helped me gas them up I
mean I'm gassing them up right now
because that's what I use so nice job
you win
um Tiffany and I have known each other
for uh what feels like uh not a long
time at all but also an eternity which
is the way that you like you know
friends to feel like there's there's
deep history but also we're not bored of
each other yet which is which is why she
was like y'all come on and talk to you
for an hour that I can do
I love doing it I also think I mean it's
like some people know this most people
should know this Mark and I have the
same birthday so I feel like that is
part of the bond too that like
I every time I every time I post memes
about Sagittarius it's like me and Mark
same thing
uh yes and so Tiffany and I continue to
threaten to throw a joint birthday party
at some time
um we have not done it yet
um but it'll it'll happen it'll happen
we'll do it at the canteen we'll have a
grand old time yeah
um and also uh we share that same
birthday with the late Chadwick Bozeman
which is always uh Bittersweet
um and also Tiffany and I have been
involved in at least two professional
Productions together
um we uh I was a writer on Master's
universe and she was in mass of the
universe Revelation
um and uh she was also gracious enough
to donate a couple days of her time to
come and make a short film with me
called Splinter
which has now uh scheduled its first
public screenings or in a couple of
weeks at the pan-african film festival
here in Los Angeles
um and uh and I'm so excited to see to
see Tiffany and uh and her friends on
the big screen in front of other people
it's I think it's one of the coolest
things about being in this industry is
meeting people and then like following
each other's journey and getting to help
each other out and be a part of projects
and stuff where it's like
we both started in very different parts
of the industry than where we are right
now and so when we first met it was more
like journalist kind of talk and things
and how are we transitioning to this
other side and sort of get to a place
where you know it was doing animated
stuff and doing voice over for it and
how excited I was and I was like not
only is this my first character that I
get to take through the whole season but
it's on a show with my friends who wrote
it which makes me feel that much more
excited and confident
um and then of course when you like I'm
doing a short I was like yes I will be
sleeping person in chair whatever you
need me for I'm there excellent
um and so when when uh when this episode
came around and I was like it's time to
start talking about last of us
um I was like who do I know who would be
fun
um and then I asked Tiffany if she'd
watch it she said no but I will
[Laughter]
that is pretty much how it went down he
was like have you watched yet I was like
I have not yet he's like well and I was
like and I have not played the game
um but I I had I had a plan to watch but
ever like I'm kind of a scaredy cat so
everyone had been like oh it's really
scary and I was like okay so I need to
plan a time that I can watch it and then
watch something that's like
light-hearted afterwards to kind of
clean the sleep before I go to sleep
um
and when I tell you that like I started
the first episode watched the second one
and then immediately started the first
one again because the third one hadn't
come out yet
I it wasn't as scary as everyone made me
think it was gonna be and I love every
second of the show
well then we are going to have ourselves
a ripper and conversation
um and not because I didn't like it I
like it quite a bit I was I was in the
bag for it because I played the game
um slash games and uh and was telling
Kevin about these games like years ago
and about how great they were it's it's
you know it's less about the playthrough
and it's more about the story and this
character journey of this this broken
man who discovers his Humanity through
you know this like Lone Wolf and cubby
Mission if I've got to escort this
person from one place to another
um and the game is just wonderful in so
many ways
um but the show is different from the
game in in ways both small and large the
largest of them being episode three
um which if anybody has watched it and
I'm assuming that you have because
you're here
um and we know who we are people thank
you spoilers we are going to talk
spoilers if you haven't watched it yes
we are going to talk spoilers I'm not
gonna spoil the game though I'm gonna
leave that stuff out because I know what
happens unless they deviate wildly from
it but I also get the feeling that the
reasons why you make the show is because
you want to get to that same endpoint as
the as the game did so I'll leave that
I'll leave the deeper spoilers uh uh
unspoiled I'll be the person who like
read The Game of Thrones books and then
watched invite people over to watch the
Red Wedding like I know what's gonna
happen it's gonna be so cool I just want
to watch you watch it uh yeah I'll be
there I'll be the [__] in the corner
watching people but watch
um Last of Us yeah I can't feel anything
because like I said I didn't play the
game and I probably like I threw doing
voiceover and being playing other games
being into games I've heard a lot about
the game so I probably have stuff in the
back of my mind but I'm like oh I kind
of I might remember things later but I
won't spoil anything from the game
really that's funny that's fair
um so are you a zombie person generally
so I am not generally a zombie person I
remember when I first started reading
The Walking Dead that I was at a comic
shop and it was like early early when
the comic started and they were like you
should read this it's amazing I was like
I don't really like zombies and I don't
really like black and white
um and they're like it's not about the
zombies it's like about humanity and
then I started reading I was like yes I
love this
um and so I think
there is always something where it's
like if you can contrast humans and
their behavior to zombies or some kind
of monsters
um I think you get some really cool
stories and that has definitely been my
experience so far within three episodes
of The Last of Us
are you a uh post-apocalypse person
watching post-apocalypse
I do
has weird Balancing Act of like that
first episode there's so much stuff in
there where you can find articles that
talks about you know cordyceps and all
the things that they're discussing and
things that are happening in the world
where it almost feels a little too close
to home where you're like how close are
we to something like this actually
happening
um
but I'm not not so much of a doom
prepper that like you know I'm not like
Bill you're not bill
um yeah there's there's a bit in uh I
guess in the second episode they talk
about I guess the origins of it a little
bit like where it comes from and then in
episode three Joel does say well some
people say that it was spread through
this cereal you know through the things
that we that we you know do we use every
day that everybody uses every day that's
how it spreads so fast
um which didn't make me feel great
because like again close to home like
don't tell me it's spread through the
food
all right come on guys like just leave
me now leave me now there was a there
was a show it used to be on I want to
say like the Discovery Channel the
Science Channel
it's called Life After People it was a
documentary thing it's basically like
let's say people disappeared from the
Earth today what happens to like cities
and then they would do it by like in one
week in one month in one year in 10
years and it would all be like just
showing the collapse of the systems that
held things in place like here's where
the Moss begins to grow here's when the
power goes out because there's nobody
Manning you know the electrical
factories here's when the air gets
better here's when the like the dams
begin to crack because nobody's
maintained like all of just the little
ways that worlds begin to to erode
without people being there
um and then sort of watch stuff like
Last of Us especially in the second
episode once they get out of the the qz
and they're into like Greater Boston and
just watching like buildings toppled and
watching the moss grow and what happens
to a hotel lobby like all that stuff is
just like you know catnip to me I'm like
oh yeah no that looks creepy well and
even like I I will say I think that
the first episode for me was I was on
the edge of my seat the whole time
because I I mean again maybe it's
because it felt close to home where it's
like
there were moments over the last couple
of years where things have happened and
you're like what would I do in that
situation how would I get out of La if I
needed to and you're watching it happen
and it's like people would go bananas
you wouldn't know where to go and this
is I will admit this
um two reasons that I got my motorcycle
license one I really like Sons of
Anarchy uh and two I was like if
anything ever happens
if I can ride a motorcycle I probably
could get out of places easier and I
don't need a ton of gas
um so yes I mean maybe in that way I'm
like a little bit of a proper tiny bit
that is uh that's the greatest thing
I've ever heard it's like listen it's
because I like this TV show and also the
apocalypse I feel like that's a lot of
things
just why I'm an actor where I'm like oh
that seems cool I want to learn that for
five minutes
um okay to the boys and girls and others
uh at home who are not caught up to date
on on the Last of Us or have not even
watched it yet again we're gonna spoil
the [__] out of it so if that is the
case if that is you then maybe just like
go and make a lot of toast for like 20
minutes
um you know like make it nice and nice
like make it just the right level of
brown like then like you do the toast
you pull it out you put the butter on
and then you put it back in the toaster
while it's still hot I have the the
toaster oven not a toaster toaster if
you have a toaster toaster don't do that
you're gonna burn up your house but if
you're gonna toaster oven slide it back
the butter will melt just right and then
you bring it back out then you can smear
it and it's glorious and glistening and
shiny go do that for like 20 minutes and
we're going to talk about last of us and
then we'll come back
um it is about a phylum Joel
um who was living in Austin the day
everything went to [__] which was
September something in 2003
um where he and his daughter played by
uh attendee Wayne Uh Newton's daughter
um which was like she's great
um [__] Pedro Pascal is just giving
deep like Clint Eastwood Burt Reynolds
Vibes in this as the the last the last
man standing at the edge of the world
um and so he and his daughter are trying
to get out of a uh Austin that is
rapidly being taken over by
um cordyceps by a fungal people infected
by a fungal
um infection as opposed to a viral
infection that's turning them into like
mushroom monsters zombies I think
um
and so we see we see the world collapse
in a day we see planes drop out of the
sky we see people running Panic we see
you know military guys just being
ordered to shoot to kill because they
don't know what to do and that
apparently the default for uh for the
military at least in Texas was shoot
everybody who uh who you don't know to
be verifiably
um healthy
and so his daughter dies
spoilers
um his uh his brother just kind of
vanishes into The Ether we don't know
what happened between them but when we
pick up 20 years later Joel is like
disposing of children's bodies
in a burn pit because that's how in the
quarantine Zone run by
um fedra which seems to be the uh the
the weird mixture of like the homeland
security meets like EMTs meets the Army
um has has uh the way they deal with
people who might be infected is you kill
them as humanely as you can and then you
burn the body so that the infection
doesn't spread
um he's a hollowed out husk of a man
because again aforementioned daughter
dying
um and uh and so the story seems to be
one about Joel finding a way to regain
his Humanity through this mission that
he's entrusted with which is escort
Ellie uh played by Bella Ramsey who
seems to be the one person in all the
world who is immune to to this fungal
infection she she has been bitten and
has never turned and so he's got to get
her to the fireflies who want to
synthesize
um something using her blood she's not
entirely sure what nobody's entirely
sure what
and the fireflies are basically Rebels
the fireflies are basically Rebels it's
the Rebel Alliance and fedra is you know
the Empire and uh and so our guys have
to leave
um the the shittiest version of Boston
and I say that with uh only a tiny
amount of love for Boston because I'm a
New Yorker so some things are bred into
the blood
so like Boston that looks about right
this is how like the last time I was
there
uh and so they have to leave Boston and
they've got to Traverse the Wilderness
um on their way to Wyoming or Wisconsin
it was a w State and I can't remember
which
um to find his brother
um and who used to be a firefly and then
to hand off Ellie and then go about
whatever life Joel thinks he's going to
be able to to retain
um potentially with his girlfriend named
Tess played by fringes anatore who I
thought was Carrie [__] for the entire
first episode
until I was like oh oh oh Fringe there
she is yep
um and so yeah that's the basic plot
it's it's a rogue movie picture it's an
adventure thing it's traversing The
Forbidden West
um to find a way to Salvation
um and along the way people will die
um people will discover who they are
people will
um find deep and Abiding Love
um
and that's just the first three episodes
yeah yeah I mean I think
the the like I said the craziest part to
me was watching the beginning and
literally looking over at my vitamin
stash where I'm like I have so many
powders that are made of mushrooms
[Laughter]
and if you're watching in Los Angeles
I'm sure that you do too
um
I'm like am I indoctrinating myself so
when this happens it won't affect me or
am I making myself a ready vessel for
when this does happen I don't know
um but the the way that they handle
things on the show with that I thought
was so cool because also I will say this
I've not played games but I'm a huge
dork and I like watching all the like
after chat show kind of stuff where the
creators are talking about the game and
things that they've changed and why they
did certain things
um and like that is one of my favorite
things about
film and television where you're gonna
make something that's in a fantasy world
but they still went so in depth on the
science to try and figure out like how
can this actually work how much of this
would be realistic how do we figure out
how this can spread and that was one of
the things I know they changed from the
game because in the game
um a lot of it is spread by spores which
they Airborne that part away on this one
which I get because it's like how do you
show that and how would everyone just
not always everyone just would be
infected all the time if you can't see
it in the game format
um yeah I mean the game played a lot
with like gas masks was a thing that you
know characters put on with with decent
regularity
um and you can't do that that much I
mean though I will say Patrick Pascal
has experience in occasionally playing a
character who wears a mask a lot
um it's hard to dramatize these two
characters if they're both cloaked in
World War II era yeah um defensive grids
um and also I should mention that the
game was written and created and
produced
um through a company called Naughty Dog
for the PlayStation by Neil druckner and
the TV show has been created with Neil
truckman
um by uh by chernobyl's own
um Craig Mason not that he's from
Chernobyl but he did Chernobyl for HBO
and won a boatload of Emmys for it
um
yeah I mean the the science of it is
always
um fascinating and then once you have to
conjure into three-dimensional space a
two-dimensional world like you've got to
build it all you've got to find a place
to shoot it all you've gotta design
everything you've got to get everything
right down to the last clothes that
people had ever manufactured like what
does that look like you know like
there's lots of people online who are
like well so they live in a world that
never had a Shrek too like oh my God
like pop culture ends in 2003 so like
there's no more albums there's no more
movies there's no more books there's
none of the things that we know over the
last 20 years exist in this world
um yeah and so just figuring out the
hollowness of what it feels like without
culture
um at least culture that progresses you
know is very much a retro focused show
because it kind of has to be yeah yeah
it I think that that's I always talk
about this because I'm like there's so
many jobs in this industry that like
usually you watch things and it's like
people are like I want to be a writer I
want to be a director I want to be an
actor
um but that stuff to me is where I'm
like I love hearing everybody else who
works on shows talk about their jobs
because you don't get a show like The
Last of Us without having the effects
teams and the costumer and hair makeup
and you know the music advisors like
there's so much stuff that goes into
making this show or any show as good as
it is and when it's great and everyone's
working together you don't notice any of
it and that's the part that I always
think is so crazy because it's like it
a lot of times those people don't get
their flowers because you're just like
I'm just watching the show and it looks
really amazing
um but you don't ever think about it
unless it's bad and then you notice
um
and I have not felt that way at all
about this show like I
every second of it I am taking in the
whole environment like you're talking
about where it's like it is really cool
to see what would the world actually be
like and then I always think would I
survive I don't know I don't know
yeah I uh I I don't imagine I think I'd
survive the first wave but I don't know
if I'd keep on Surviving after that
you know like I'm I'm generally a sharp
enough person to be able to figure out
like problem a it's when you get to
problem Z or even [__] J we're like
oh oh damn I don't know what to do about
that yeah I just don't like I'm not a
doomsday prepper at all I could not be
bill I could not build you know a
electrified fence with you know flame
mortars and bungee pits and all that
stuff no and you know I'm like
happy positive optimistic
I would want to believe the best in
everyone so my brain wouldn't be like
how do I fortify my space from anyone
coming in here because I would be like
you can come in just come on like and
that was those are the hardest parts
when you're watching the show and the
first episode when they're driving out
of Austin and they pass people and Joel
is like do not stop the car
[Music]
it's like he literally says that's a kid
they have kids and he's like I have a
daughter
and it's just brutal when you watch that
happen because you're like I get what
he's saying but like how could you could
would I do that how would I mean
yeah the the I mean that is always the
uh the the Crux of apocalyptic fiction
right which is would I be able to
survive would I be able to make it out
um and I think a similarly decent
question is what meal Tiffany Smith
would somebody have to cook you in order
to get you to stay with them for 20
years
what what what's the like you're at the
bottom of a hole someone is like all
right come on in I want to have lunch
all right I'll cook you lunch oh gosh
what would it be well what what would
you cook somebody
oh what would you cook somebody and then
what would you want to have them cook
for you uh well
I would cook breakfast because that's
maybe one of the only things I feel like
I'm decent at like I can cook eggs and
bacon and pancakes and
um
but if I'm talking in the apocalypse I
don't know where I'm getting bacon from
maybe I could find some chickens but I
don't think I'd be able to slaughter a
pig on my own so so we'd probably have
eggs and pancakes and that would be what
I would make yeah all right I mean you'd
have to have cows
in order to get milk right you'd be
you'd have to be churning butter no no I
will have saved those like I will have
found some of those old like shaky
containers to make pancake mix that you
put water in okay
I got a fridge full of I Can't Believe
It's Not Butter it's fine no those don't
have to go in the fridge the powder mix
they don't have to go in the fridge
so I would find those somehow
um
you're making breakfast for somebody
yeah yeah and then and then so what
would you what would you want to have
had somebody make you
what's what's the ideal Tiffany Smith
so lame and I've said it a billion times
but I
my favorite meal is a baked potato with
cheddar cheese bacon butter
maybe a little sour cream or ranch
dressing on the side and a black and
white milkshake
if they had that I would stay with them
forever
[Laughter]
and maybe even some of uh Nick
offerman's luggable and I would have
that yeah a good a good 20-year
um casc aged Scotch which I again not a
plug if you have not tried I I like
whiskey and scotch
a special one with Lagos and it is
so good like I highly recommend trying
it if you are a scotch whiskey person
um I feel like what this is calling for
is a special black man beyond episode
where we try all of these celebrity
boozes
like let's try Sam hewan Scotch from
Outlander let's try Nick Offerman Scotch
let's get some of that tiramana stuff
let's get Clooney's you know casamigos
there's there's a raft of like
I'm famous and so I made a thing
bill on the episode last of us
um he is very into
um Scott twisky and stuff and like I
remember him posting about isn't there I
feel like there's even an episode in oh
yeah yeah
where he goes to the lagu woman
Distillery yeah yeah um yeah because
because Leslie no sends him there
because he thinks that there's nothing
in the United Kingdom there's nothing in
Europe worth
um worth a damn yeah so she sends him on
this wonderful little kind of treasure
hunt and the end of which is him just on
the Isle of Skye just like looking out
into the Horizon drinking scotch
reading like Robert Frost or something
yeah he would get along very well
excellent
um okay what would your meals be
um would you what would you have had
what would you have cooked for you uh
the the meal that I would like to have
cooked it's it's very much like you know
the end of the menu which uh which you
know spoilers if you haven't seen the
menu but make me a great [__]
cheeseburger you know like I it is it is
less for me the fancy and more for me
the familiar that becomes like I can't
get the thing that I want this is the
thing that you know that makes me feel
emotionally warm and safe and satisfied
Sarah make me a [__] great
cheeseburger yeah um you know the thing
that I would cook for somebody
um would I think require a the the the
the the the slaying of a pig
because I make a very good
um pork loin
um rubbed with a bunch of spices and
then with like a sweet potato like a
soft sweet potato puree with [__]
cinnamon and butter and sugar and all
that
and like just walk a couple of
vegetables by the plate and then bring
them back out into the into the yard
because at that point you don't eat
vegetables who are we kidding
uh yeah that's that's where I think I go
a good spice
yeah pork loin
um but okay so let's talk about episode
three I mean each of these episodes are
very much about introducing you to a
world right like episode one introduces
you to the world of the qz of the
quarantine Zone the world that used to
be and now the world that is
episode two is about introducing you to
both you know Boston larger Boston and
what the apocalypse looks like and who
the zombies and what the zombies are
they give us the rules of the zombies
um but episode three is very much about
an emotional world it's very much about
um these two men who just meet on the
opposite sides of offense who over the
course of 20 years form
a
deliriously wonderful life together
um you know it's played by it's Frank
and Bill
um Murray Bartlett from from White Lotus
um and HBO's looking and a bunch of
other stuff
um and the great and wonderful Nick
Offerman
um and it's just their lives together it
is just the sort of tentative Beginnings
it is the we're getting to know each
other it's the fights that you have when
you live with somebody for a decade
which are both Petty and large
um there are the we're gonna have people
over for dinner what do we do then and
of course the people who come home for
dinner are Joel and Tess and how Joel's
life interacts with with Bill who never
liked Joel I did love the fact that they
hated each other even even then
um and then and then ultimately the the
end of their relationship because Frank
has a terminal illness which they don't
ever tell us what it is um I mean I
think it's probably cancer
um if not something you know even more
um viral and invasive
yeah they don't it doesn't seem like
it's a cordyceps thing it doesn't seem
like he's been infected by the Zombie
Plague it just seems like it's something
and I don't want to use the word mundane
because that's not quite right but it's
something just human like the human body
failed him in ways that there was no
cure for before the the apocalypse and
now there's no cure for afterwards
and so how do you how do you choose to
live your own life how do you choose the
manner in which you want your life to
end
um you know do you choose dignity or or
do you choose The Natural end of things
and it's it's heartbreaking the fact you
know heartbreaking but also you 100
understand it
and Frank is like I don't wanna I don't
want to just wither away I just don't
want to be that person I don't want to
end on my own terms and so feel this
goblet with with this baggie of crushed
up hills and you'll put me to sleep and
the last thing that I will see is the
man that I love standing over me and
gently closing my eyes as I pass
like which is wonderful and and you know
it is it is the sweetest romance you
know I think somebody said it's like the
first 10 minutes of up but
it is it literally is like what I
thought I remember when I was watching
the episode I like paused it for a
minute because I had to take my dog for
a walk and then when I passed I was like
please let there be at least 20 minutes
left I don't want this episode to be
over like I wanted to keep going and I
think this episode was it was like an
hour and 20 minutes
yeah it's it's a long one yeah but it
definitely feels like
like you said it's a short film you know
it is this love story that when I first
started watching the episode I had no
idea what was coming
um
and I love the fact that it was it was
done in such a way where for the first
like
quarter of it I guess I was just nervous
the whole time of like what this guy
gonna do like is he gonna try and Kill
Bill Kill Bill
um is he gonna try and steal stuff from
him like shocked that they'll actually
trusted him enough to like let him
shower or leave him in a room because
I'm thinking like here's this guy who
has made an oasis for himself where he
feels safe and here's a stranger who he
has no idea if he if he's lying or
telling the truth that he is on his own
um and lets him come in and then it's
like you're showing someone all of the
stuff that you have and how life could
be if you let him stay there or if he
took it from you
um so that was crazy because like the
whole beginning I was just so nervous
and on the edge of my seat waiting for
you know the other shoe to drop and
something terrible to happen
um and then it ends up being this like
beautiful love story and with such great
moments and I I it's like thinking about
the episode again
how they did so many moments over the
years that it felt like
you saw their whole relationship even
though it was just in bits and pieces
here and there like you know where Joel
and them do come and Joel warns them
about something and then that moment
comes and I thought I was like he's dead
they're gonna flash back again and it's
just Frank by himself and that's when
you come back and it's not Frank by
himself Frank is now sick
um so it was just so so well done
but I never really knew what exactly was
coming next
um though I did I did I was like he at
the end I was like
Bill drank it already like he's not
gonna he's not gonna stay there by
himself
um
it was that beautiful thing where he's
like I was here alone and then I now
he's like I never that one the
strawberry scene and then he's like I
never
I was never scared before
um before he met Frank and then it's
like well now he has something to
protect and has something that's
wonderful and it's not just him and he
wants to keep it and protect it and
nourish it
um
and it was like it literally was one of
the best things I've watched on TV in a
very long time yeah no it's it's a it's
a fantastic hour of TV and and it does
impact the Joel storyline the Joel and
Ellie storyline because it is the object
lesson to Joel of I didn't want to let
this person into my life and I did and
it made my life a thousand times better
I'm like Joel you have to learn to do
that
um otherwise you're gonna die alone and
sad and nobody's coming the window open
for you as your funk just emanates
the funk of forty thousand years yeah I
mean that that those were all things too
where I was like
it's so crazy when you put together an
episode and see the moments that stick
with people I mean the strawberry moment
and then Nick offerman's like giggle
that he does
for the first time and the letter
reading the letter Alex again I watched
all the stuff afterwards but they talk
about the fact that there is a letter
from Bill to Joel in the game oh no
sorry from Frank
right to build yes
um and it's very different things end
very differently in the game their
relationship in the game is antagonistic
their relationship in the game is you
know they had been lovers and they ended
badly and and they find Frank having
killed himself
um and you don't really know the tenor
of their relationship
um you know that it was close but you
don't know exactly what it was and
unless you go on a separate thing and
you find the gay porno mag that Bill had
been keeping and to realize oh it was a
sexual issue it was a romantic
relationship
um but it's a very different interaction
between those two characters and then
bill and Joel
um and so the the ability to
recontextualize what that is and have it
be not just an obstacle for a player in
a game to surmount but actually this
deep emotional story that can help turn
Joel because you know the game I think
we said it at the top the game there's
20 25 hours of gameplay in The Last of
Us video game and that's a long time to
get to move the character along an
emotional Spectrum to carry him on his
emotional Journey the show has nine
episodes that's nine hours and change to
do so and so how can you light a fire
under that emotional trajectory how can
you shift Joel's perspective on
everything
um early enough so that when you know
the bulk of that story happens when the
last two thirds of that story happens he
can be ready to receive it and this is a
great way to do that yeah well the other
thing too is that you know it got picked
up for season two
um
um but I'm like I don't like I don't
know where season one ends or how far
out they've planned where it's like how
how many seasons is it to get to the end
of the game
um yeah I think Craig Mason had said
that it's a two season show okay um
which which seems ambitious for me in
that getting sleeping the first game is
a big game but I see how you Whittle
that stuff down Last of Us Part Two is
massive
um yeah and so I don't know how you do
that in one season of TV but
you must have a plan yeah yeah I mean
and I think it's one of those things
where just looking at the three episodes
we've seen so far each one of them
even though it is not like separately
episodic they each one is at a very
different feel the first one was action
to me like get out of town kind of
craziness the second one was more horror
where it was you know those scare jumps
and
um what's gonna happen while they're
figuring out and you know Ellie is
seeing new kinds of these
um zombies or
um the creatures along the way and then
the third one is like this separate
vignette story that's telling you about
you know
how people are surviving during all of
this and I do think it's something where
it does impact Joel a lot because one
from the episode before he loses tests
and so
even though you haven't heard him like
you know they were together and that
they had a connection but I didn't you
don't really see how strong it is but
then stuff happens with Ellie where he's
like don't mention her name and you know
that it it was something that was really
close to his heart and so getting that
next to Bill and Frank
dying and then now he's got Ellie with
him so it's like okay well now he has a
choice to make again does he get even
more closed off because he lost the
person that he loved or is there a way
for him to transfer those emotions or
actually still let someone else in even
though it could end badly which it did
for him with Tess and his daughter yeah
um
so I definitely think it
pushes the story along and I know like I
had a lot of friends who are like I just
feel like I'm more plugged into these
two characters Bill and Frank that I am
with any of the other ones I'm like well
we did get the longest amount of time so
far just with them and you know a story
that is that's
you get a whole journey with them in
this one episode
um
so I understand like I feel like I know
them better than I know any of the other
characters but I also think that kind of
makes it fun because I don't want to
know exactly I I don't know exactly how
Ellie's gonna behave in every situation
I don't know how
um Joel is gonna behave in every
situation but Frank and Bill like from
that one episode now I'm like
I know I feel like I know what they
would do because we got to know them so
well and I like that there is a lot of
unknown still with the characters that
were going on this journey with yeah I
mean I I liked it the same way that I
liked I want to say it was the seventh
episode of Watchmen sixth or seventh The
Nostalgia episode where uh where where
uh Regina King
um takes the pill and she gets to relive
the life of her ancestor and it's all
black and white and it's all about you
know the first black detective on the
force and it's all about the creation of
hooded Justice and like it does not
feature for the most part your
protagonist it is not about sister
Knight it's about this this deep
character in her own backstory
um that does amplify the world but isn't
necessarily about her and so to be able
to break format of your own show and
just tell this completely somewhat
isolated slice which does relate to your
main protagonist but isn't about your
main protagonist
um I think is kind of wonderful to have
the latitude and the freedom to be able
to do that
um so I'm here for it like an actor
standpoint I'm like
they didn't meet until like those two
actors are playing Bill and Frank they
didn't meet until they were there
shooting which like
I mean I I do think being an actor you
should create in chemistry is sometimes
part of the job
um but the chemistry that the two of
them have in this episode and the whole
Arc of their story where it's you know
they did I think they said they it felt
like a short film like they were there
longer than you would be for a normal
episode
um just like one hour episode but it's
not a lot of time to like get that close
with someone and feel
be able to portray that connection in
the way that I think they did in this
episode I mean apparently the director's
cut was two hours long
um so it's like they actually did just
make a full-on [__] movie and then
had to find a way to cut 40 minutes out
of it yeah you know and I do hope that
that you know on the back end of all
this once we're all set is done that
they do release at least some extended
version of that episode
here's my question for you yeah the rest
of the season is going to play out like
do you think we're going to get other
kind of
sliced out stories like this or do you
think this was a one-off
um I don't I don't think it's a bit of a
I don't think it's a spoiler to say that
um
you know Joel and his long-lost brother
will probably find each other again
um but then discovering what his
brother's version of the last 20 years
has been you know to to then also give
us some more background to the fireflies
and who they are and where they started
and how that sort of Grassroots
Rebellion you know took shape it would
not surprise me if there's an episode
that digs deep into that you know and
who they are and what they're about and
why they're doing what they're doing and
how they got resources all of that stuff
that the creation of the fireflies and
how his brother plays into that or you
know has even lost faith with that
um would not surprise me
um but there's a lot of little stories
to tell there's a lot of I mean in the
game there's a big paradigm shift that
happens about halfway through
um that could also be fascinating if
they do it the same way in the show
um but no I have nothing but I mean
watching the pilot I was I was giddy
like but I was curious to know what a
person who's never played the game and
doesn't know what it is feels about it
because like I know where it's going so
they have me no matter what they did
yeah um but it is good to hear that a
person who has no familiarity whatsoever
with the game it's like no give me more
give me more right
I have no idea where it's going and it's
crazy because I think you know we all go
through that stuff where it's like uh
they're like superhero fatigue is there
video games made into TV shows fatigue
it doesn't necessarily work well and I'm
like it's not I don't think it's that we
have fatigue it's because if it's good
you don't care if it was a superhero
project or a video game or based off of
something else or a reboot because
you're just into it
um and this is one of those ones where
it's like everything seems to be working
really well and just right and make
people who played the game enjoy it and
have those Easter eggs in there and
people who have no idea or have a very
slight knowledge of the game
um to really enjoy the show too
yeah I mean to your point like
there's you know what was Thor Ragnarok
was what like the 19th Marvel movie or
whatever it's like but if you make a
good one if you make it good we'll we'll
be there for it you know like I'm I'm
predisposed to like genre stuff but like
I've seen enough bad genre stuff to be
like I don't have to
so like if you do it well I'm here for
it I'm here for it
um
all right so I think uh suffice to say
I'm a fan of Last of Us it seems like
Tiffany is a fan of last of us we will
um both be watching every Sunday night
um you know barring um
I don't know sprained ankles or or uh or
being airlifted to a different part of
the country without access to my cable
um for my HBO Max
um but before you go and I know that you
have to bounce it about 10 minutes
um what what was your um impression
uh about the the unspooling of the DC
um new slate because in case you know
you're you've been living under a nerd
Rock for the last week or so
um yesterday
um James Gunn took to the internet and
then took to the press and they had a
big event at DC headquarters here in
Burbank California and he he unveiled at
least the first wave of the the the
future of the DC Universe both in TV
um animation live action television and
live action feature films
um and it's ambitious it's got things
that were somewhat obvious things we
already knew and then things a little
head scratchy
um not in bad ways but just really
um what did uh how did you feel
generally about what uh what Mr Gunn had
to say
generally I am really excited
um I think that when you get someone
like James Gunn coming and doing it it's
kind of like okay well what is he gonna
do to put his stamp on it what kind of
director Creator is he and the fact that
this is Gods and Monsters
and he is great at doing kind of the
more obscure characters and horror kind
of stuff as well
um it seems like the most perfect fit
and yeah I mean I think no matter what
he would have said it's going to be a
big swing because he had to come in with
you know him and Peter saffron had to
come in with something because everyone
was waiting with baited geeky breaths to
see what they were gonna do and say
um so to me it's like
I I literally I just feel excited
because I'm like there's
there's characters that people don't
know about there's characters that no
one has in it not no one that
a lot of people don't have a
preconceived idea of who these
characters exactly are say you know
we've seen Superman Batman and yes they
are doing the Superman
um but there's these other stories where
I think that there is a lot more
flexibility where even what we saw with
Peacemaker like Peacemaker isn't exactly
like the comic but because it's a more
obscure character people got really into
the show just because it was a different
space and you kind of like allow more
changes on it because it's not Superman
that you know exactly how he's supposed
to behave all the time
um so I'm really excited about all the
stuff that's coming
um I also think it's one of those things
where now we have all these things that
have come out and they said it's in
eight to ten years so
we have a long time until this stuff
actually is all
um rolling and the last four is it four
four films still to come out yeah you
get Shazam two Aquaman 2
um flash flash join and Blue Beetle yeah
Flashpoint not flash joint that's a
totally different movie yeah
yeah I mean I I too am cautiously
optimistic
um because like
there's always a way for a movie to be
not great but they're similarly always a
way for a movie to be amazing and the
thing that was most um encouraging to me
is that uh James and and Peter Safran
you know said
we realize that the problem with these
movies is very often that the scripts
are not ready before they announce a
release date and so sometimes you're
making it up as you go by the time you
get to your third active so we're not
going to Greenlight anything until the
script is right we're not gonna you know
bring on you know all of the people we
need to like the 200 some odd people it
takes to make a movie I'm not hiring
anybody until we know the stories right
in the script is right and so that that
level of commitment to
you know what is ultimately the
ultimately the blueprint like you can't
do a good movie without a good script
you know it's it's in I won't say it's
impossible but at this level yeah it
kind of is you know like sure there are
always the stories of like Casablanca
was kind of written on the Fly Like You
Know sending in Pages here and there and
it's like yeah well we're on a set
you have eight to ten years of films
that you're maybe building to something
we don't know
um where how does this fit with this one
how does this not fit in with this one
um I think that was also something that
I think is like an easy which growing up
reading comic books I'm like there's
elseworld stuff so it never felt weird
to me having different universes and
comics and characters so that made
complete sense to me that they're saying
that some of the films are going to be
elseworlds and they'll be labeled as
that
yeah you know I I think it's it's we
have a plan and there is a strategy you
know and the fact that again like that
plan was conceived not just by you know
James and and Peter but by a a they put
together a writer's room to help build
out what this universe could feel and
look like and so you know there's a road
map that they have to follow they're not
sharing with everybody nor should they
um but all of that stuff is uh is
encouraging to say the least now we'll
see who they start hiring to do this
stuff we'll see how much James is going
to do himself he's definitely doing
Superman himself and he's already
written Creature Commandos their first
animated show under the Gods and
Monsters thing and you know he's already
expressed some affection for some of
these other characters but then we'll
see the other people that he invites
um into the into the playground to play
with these toys
I mean I think and I also think it's
cool that with Creature Commandos he
said that they're gonna do try to do
voice and live action actors crossing
over which I think is interesting and
cool and you always you know people like
even going back to the last of us where
it's like Troy Baker
um and oh my gosh Ashley
um who played the two leads in the game
where it's like
everyone was so attached to them as
those characters but for like reasons
where it's like Ashley's not young
enough to be the 14 year old girl
anymore but they're both I believe cast
in the show I don't we don't know what
roles that they're in
um so there is that thing where it's
like when people get attached to someone
playing a role whether it's voice or in
a video game then getting to see them on
screen as that character too
um I'm curious to see how that all plays
out because I think even they're doing
it in Star Trek where it's like they
took um characters from lower Decks that
are gonna cross over into strange new
worlds episode yeah like Jack Quaid you
know specifically it's definitely going
between the two and yeah that's super
fun if you can pull it off like it's
it's a heavy lift but if you can pull it
off that's that's neat yeah that's neat
all right ladies and gentlemen we have
to bid uh Miss Tiffany Smith a fund
adieu
um as she has got to go off and like
fight crime
no I I can say so I am leaving because I
booked a thriller
um and I start filming in a couple of
days here
um so for the life of an actor it's very
fast turned around
um yeah I'm really excited it's with the
same producers
um Fades of black that I did Aloha with
love and this one
um like I said it's a thriller so I get
to
and possibly do some stunty badassness
and I'm excited about that do they know
you can ride a motorcycle
they do
yeah like I don't think I'm riding a
motorcycle
uh well thank you for spending an hour
out of your precious like last couple of
days of prep with us to talk about nerd
[__]
I always I'm so happy to do it yay well
thank you Tiffany and best of luck
um thrilling and chilling wherever
you're going to go and do that I'm sure
you'll be fabulous because you're never
anything less than
um and we'll see you when you get back
sounds good bye everybody
uh all right now that she's gone
um no we're uh we're gonna we're gonna
run down the stuff that they announced
um from the DC you know that's not it
like we're not just saying peace out
that's been it for this episode of black
man beyond now we're going to talk a
little bit about
um all of the things that they announced
um and by they I mean James Gunn
um so uh so overall the plan is is two
movies a year
um two series for each and two series
for HBO Max in what is going to be like
an eight to ten year plan and what they
revealed was not the entirety of that
plan I think or at the very least you
know portion of this Gods and Monsters
phase is going to spill out between 2025
and 2027 so we have a ways to wait
before we get to see
um all of this Joy
um The Writer's room that I said that
they assembled includes you know gun and
saffron
um and then Christina Hodson
um Jeremy Slater Drew Goddard Crystal
Henry and Tom King comic book writer Tom
king
um
and they've all done you know things
Great and Small um Jeremy Slater was one
of the people who developed Umbrella
Academy
um he was on board for Moon night we've
seen Hudson did the Bumblebee movie and
a bunch of other stuff that's that's
just terrific Drew Goddard Cabin in the
Woods Buffy Angel
um
um what was the name of that Hotel movie
that he did that I cannot remember the
name of which I also I quite liked um
and wrote and was Oscar nominated for
the Martian
um Crystal Henry who was on Watchmen and
Tom King we know Tom King because you
know we're all those guys
um
so let's go through what they're doing
and these are all happening after
um the four movies that they have
already as we talked about Shazam
um Flash and then
um Aquaman and the lost kingdom and then
uh Blue Beetle
um
here we go
Creature Commandos
um is first out of the gate
um James Gunn has written every episode
of this apparently it's done
um it's animation
um Creature Commandos is comprised of
military superhumans including a human
leader werewolf vampire frankincense
monster and a gorgon
um so like you know 30 dozen meets Clash
of the Titans meets you know
um League of Extraordinary Gentlemen a
bit
um Waller which we also already knew
about
um and James had had hinted that he
wrote you know all or most of
um a new DC thing he hinted it back a
while ago and that clearly was Creature
Commandos
um Waller starring Viola Davis
um is in HBO Max live action series
spinning out a peacemaker
um Superman Legacy
which is the Superman movie that the
James has been
um writing which he announced that he
was doing already
um according to Peter Safran this is
really the start of the DCU
um it's not an origin story it focuses
in Superman's balancing his crotonian
Heritage with his human upbringing
he's the embodiment of truth justice in
the American way he's his kindness in a
world that thinks of kindness as
old-fashioned there's no director
attached but of course you know uh
there's always the chance that the guy
who wrote this could direct the movie
um and there's no casting you know I
think for for any of this stuff other
than
um Waller
um lanterns and HBO Max live action
series
um our vision for this is True Detective
saffron says it's terrestrial base he's
it's got two of our favorite Green
Lanterns Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart
um and it plays a really big role in the
main story that we're telling across
film and TV
um
and it is different from the one that
Greg berlandi has had in the works
um that has been in development for the
past year if not longer um that one was
a Space Opera that was like out in the
in the in the Hinterlands of the cosmos
where this one is going to be clearly it
said on Earth
um this is the one that's getting me
excited
and
um it's because it's it's the comic book
like because I all right I'm gonna
rewind a little bit it's a comic fan
when I was in like Elementary School
junior high and top of high school
um and then it got a little expensive I
I was uh the X-Men had done like nine
crossovers in a row on these sort of
multi-title arcs
um I think this one was Extinction
agenda with the last one that I read and
it kind of just soured me on Comics
there was too much to read there was too
many books I had to buy in order to get
the complete story it was
it felt almost abusive in that way and I
sort of parted ways with comics for a
long time like middle of high school
um throughout College
um I didn't really collect I didn't
really buy like I might have gone back
and read some of my old stuff but I
wasn't engaging in the new um very much
at all
um and I got my first job after college
at a science fiction magazine called
Starla and um
and they used to get
um uh the comp box like every every
um every publisher and by every I mean
Marvel in DC for the most part would
send the big box of comics
um one of everything that they did that
particular month it would go to various
press places and there were not a ton of
places at the time that were covering
Comics so it would have been you know
I'm sure there was a writer at like the
New York Times I'm sure there was
somebody at Time Magazine you know but
starlog was a pretty big you know geek
monthly magazine at the time and so my
editor Dave McDonald got this box from
Marvel in DC every month and he would
pull out the ones that he won wanted and
then you know it's it would then go down
the the hierarchy of who could then pick
from the litter next and from one of
those boxes I picked out
um
I I want to say it was like Authority
number two
um and it was you know Warren Ellis and
Brian hitch and it was it was billed as
you know widescreen uh Comics like
everything was was about scale it was
all about action and and big fleets of
ships and giant swarms of bad guys and
and and heroes that were able to like
you know Apollo had the power of the Sun
and so we could just Scorch things and
Jenny Sparks had like like it was it was
just big it was big in a way that that I
hadn't quite experienced in comics
before and it was that book that kind of
brought me back into reading comics
um The Authority was a wild storm book
before Wild Storm got Incorporated to DC
um and I loved it to death
um it made me a fan of of both Comics
again of superhero comics again of
Warren Ellis
um who uh who I followed from book to
book to book to book to book
um and I and I actually got to write the
authority
um for for a little bit there before um
before wildstorm kind of collapsed in on
itself a little bit
um and so I have a super soft spot in my
heart for the authority and that is one
of the movies it's going to be a big
feature um that they have planned
um according to to James like there's a
great while some characters were popular
for a long time and were cooperating
them into the DCU
um he loves a property because it's a
mix of anti-heroes who take matters into
their own hands despite what governments
advise
um and so that's the one that's the one
that I'm super excited about
um I've loved that book for a long time
to get to see it at that scale to get to
see it in the sort of Blockbuster format
that it was always intended to be
um and then to be able to thumb its nose
a little bit at the the uh the DC status
quo
um you know they were never quite as
outrageous as the boys were
um you know uh although you know Garth
Ennis didn't have his time writing the
authority
um which did take it into a dirtier path
than even Warren Ellis did
um but uh but I just think that that
those characters are so sharp and
they're acerbic and they and they
they do that there is a bit of Anarchy
to them which is always fun in a
superhero construct
um so yes the authority is coming
um Paradise Lost is an HBO Max live
action series which is you know as they
describe it Game of Thrones on
themiskira
um the drama is really about the
political Intrigue behind the Society of
all women how did that come about what's
the beautiful truth is ugly shoes behind
all that and what's the scheming like
between power players in that Society
um and it takes place before the birth
of Diana of the mosquito so even though
it would be about a bunch of Wonder
Women there's going to be no wonder
woman unless I suppose at some point you
can always catch up with that
um and there can be a season finale
where the child is born on an island
where presumably there are not a ton of
children
um
then you finally get your Batman
um the Brave and the Bold as a movie
um and this is this is the the DCU
version of Batman
um which is different entirely from the
one that that Matt Reeves is doing
um this will feature Batman and the son
Damian Wayne as Robin who was according
to to James Gunn is a little son of a
[__]
um assassin murderer
um and Batman takes him in
um who doesn't know that Batman he's
Batman's actual son or doesn't the
Batman exists for the first 10 years of
his life
um and it's based on Grant Morrison's
run on Batman and you know as Tiffany
said the Matt Reeves Batman is going to
exist now in an else worlds
um Silo along with the Joker movies
um
so so yes we will have more than one
Batman
um which is actually kind of fascinating
and I don't know how that will dovetail
with whatever post credit whatever Cameo
stuff they shot for the flash
um there will be a version where yeah
we're gonna see two different Batman on
the same screens under the same DC logo
um you know Matt Reeves Batman 2 is
going to be out October 3rd 2025 with
Robert Pattinson
um and but they are going to cast a new
guy
um to be the Batman for a brave of the
Bold
um
and they did not mention Ben Affleck
other than as a director at some point
for some film in the in this new DCU
Booster Gold is going to be an HBO Max
TV series
um it's about a loser from the future he
uses future technology to come back and
pretend to be a superhero
um Supergirl woman of tomorrow as a big
old feature based on Tom King's um very
recent comic series I think it's if it
hasn't just ended it's just wrapping up
um uh in our series says um either
Gunner saffron not sure where this quote
is from
um we see the difference between
Superman who was sent to Earth and
raised by loving parents from the time
he was an infant
um versus Supergirl who was raised on a
rock a chip off of Krypton and watched
everyone around her die and be killed in
terrible ways for the first 14 years of
her life and then she comes to earth
when she's a young girl she's much more
hardcore and definitely not the super
girl that we're used to seeing
and then
um finally uh Swamp Thing as as a
feature
um and and even after like James gone
unspooled all of this stuff
um yesterday and then today the news
broke that James Mangold coming off of
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
who did Logan
um is interested in doing Swamp Thing
um I mean there's no deal yet but
there's an offer apparently on the table
um and then Mangold has been a big fan
of small thing and he's been chasing a
feature for a while
um according to uh the according to gun
and saffron there are some rules
according in their Universe anyone cast
in the DC TV side as a character will
also play their character in the film
side and no one actor will play two
parts hence uh Jason Momoa is Aquaman
and will always be Aquaman I guess maybe
but he won't be low he won't be Lobo as
well
um
and uh and apparently the the Warner
Brothers Discovery investment is huge
um there's no question that they have
the resources
um they're going to put their scripts
together get their directors and then
discuss with with
um
David zazlov who's the CEO of Warner
Brothers Discovery what the appropriate
spend is on each one of these movies uh
and uh and so for instance he has zero
doubt that they will commit the
appropriate funds on each one the stakes
are high and it's a it was a brand in
crisis and this is an opportunity to
build an extraordinary Standalone studio
with the best IP and the best stories in
the world
um so that's it that's that's what we're
getting in the immediate future
um this is this is kind of what it looks
like
um
I'm I'm like I said cautiously
optimistic I mean there's there's
characters that people know and love and
recognize
um namely Superman and Batman
um and Robin
um and then there's the the left field
stuff that that might not be
um if not popular like I don't know how
many people these days give that much of
a hoot about Swamp Thing it's a great
character but you know even though they
have the CW Series which which I
actually found pretty strong
um that got canceled after one season oh
no that was DC Universe thing and then
it went to the CW that's right
um you know so there's the characters
that everybody knows the characters
somebody have people do have some slight
familiarity with that have been movies
have been made about before and there's
stuff like the authority you know that
uh that is a complete left field choice
but it's one that I kind of love because
those characters are so great and those
stories are so fun
um so that is all the DC news that's fit
to print about the new stuff
um there are a couple of you know I
guess bookends to it or news stories
that broke simultaneously or just before
just after that uh there are a couple of
DC things that won't be continuing at
HBO Max
um Titans Doom Patrol and Penny worth
um are all wrapping up after their
current seasons
um we're gonna get uh you know the
conclusions of seasons four on on Titans
and Doom Patrol they have their second
half so the fourth Seasons to come up
and they'll be final chapters and
apparently they've been crafted to give
the series a real ending and then penny
worth just aired its third season and
that will be the end of that particular
a run
and that's uh a lot of DC news
um
but yeah I mean like like I said with
Tiffany like it's encouraging to me that
that James as a writer as a writer
director as a Storyteller understands
that without the stories it's hard to
build a universe it's hard to have all
these things connecting ways that are
meaningful it's hard to I mean even make
a single movie without a script that's
right let alone a universe let alone a
series of movies that have to
interconnect and TV shows it's a it's a
very complex task to do
then the only way to do it is to be able
to be clear that these scripts are as
ready as they possibly can be before you
spend the money and shoot them
um so the fact that writers are at the
high of his list
um is encouraging to me
and I root for everybody to win I don't
want anybody to lose and so I think DC
has been on its back heels for about a
decade now of uh of of maybe not the
best versions of what they have what
they could have had
um you know it's a it's it's hurting
cats to a certain degree and at least
now they've decided to herd dogs
um so
which you know again not easy but still
dogs listen
um so that is almost it for the news
um there was one last PostScript
um that I wanted to talk about and that
is
[Music]
um
the actress Annie Worsham
um who uh was on TV shows like 24 and
Timeless
um she was on the rookie and she was the
board Queen in the second season of Star
Trek Picard has passed away she died of
cancer
um at 45 years old earlier this week
um
she you know a connection to our
previous conversation she was the
original voice of Tess in The Last of Us
um video game the character that is now
played by uh Diana Torv
um you know I I never got to meet her
although I did work on on Picard season
two
um but I do know a bunch of people who
were on that show I do know a bunch of
people who are on other shows of tours
on who never had a bad thing to say
about her
um
uh she was incredibly well liked she was
a terrific performer
um and it sounds by all reports that
she'll be desperately missed not just by
her family
um but by you know an audience that had
embraced her for you know almost 20
years
um
so yes pour one out for uh for any
worshiping
um too soon far too soon
um and I think that is that is that is
all we have I don't know JC Batman do we
have some questions from the Q a from
the from the from the The Good Fellas
and ladies and all the in-betweenies
yeah we can do some uh we can do some
show some questions that I've collected
throughout how are you JC we didn't even
get a chance to talk at the topic uh I'm
good I took a trip to the east coast
last week
um I lived in Hoboken New Jersey Once
Upon a Time 20 years ago
oh has it changed
it's uh
it's funny it's almost exactly the same
except completely different like
Blockbuster Video is now an anthropology
and like you know the old mom and pop
pizza shop is now a Shake Shack
uh but they're all in the old buildings
so that was super interesting uh but it
was a good uh it was a good fun trip I
was also at Sundance
I saw some people being like there
hasn't been a show in three weeks it's
like well I haven't been home for two of
them
um
and uh I was surprised at how much I
didn't like Sundance really it was it
just felt like chaos
uh just chaos and and everybody at
Sundance is from Los Angeles but like
not not the Los Angeles that I spend
time with so
that's a nice way of saying it so uh
yeah it's been things are good though
things are things have been good I got
um
my mother-in-law
even though we're not married because of
pandemic but mother-in-law uh came down
from upstate New York and we took
um
Jocelyn into New York City to FAO
Schwartz which they've reopened goodness
Rockefeller and she's never been to a
toy store
uh so that was like pure joy you know
you go to Target
but it's not the same as like going to
Toys R Us like you have to walk through
all the so we just let her run around
three floors of FAO shorts which was
just fantastic wow you got her out of
there a highlight of my trip was that
outstanding yeah I haven't I haven't
been up to to that much I haven't
traveled anywhere or done much of
anything other than work
um you know and as as per usual it's on
things that I can't talk about yet only
because it's not in my purview to say
what those things are
um
uh when when information can be spilled
I'm sure that they will be spilled right
here um one of the things I think Kevin
has mentioned we're doing together
um which is super fun
um as always uh but yeah it's been it's
been busy with good busy
um you know slowly still trying to get
myself back out into the world in in
real ways
um and hopefully I mean it's been it's
been a long time since I've been to The
Cantina I was thinking about that the
other day I kind of miss it I miss I
missed the Cantina
I can say so maybe I can say something
here gosh I don't know if I can I'll say
uh let's see what I can say uh we are
going to be redoing our front little
room and making it leaning into
[Music]
the Star Trek of things more in our
front room
because
March is going to be Star Trek month at
scum and villainy
and nice thing and I believe
we are going to be doing an official
Star Trek event
in in the month of March so we're gonna
we're we're uh we're doing some upgrades
getting ready for
um for this cool thing
in March so if you're planning a trip
and you like Star Trek
um and I guess also
in February there's a Star Trek Cruise
that's leaving from Long Beach and
there's there's like this whole group of
Star Trek
people who are flying into LA to go to
the cruise and I got added to their
Facebook group because they're all going
to come to scum and villainy the night
before the cruise leaves in costume oh
my goodness oh excellent It's the
coolest Facebook group I've seen in a
long time because I've got people being
like
are there gyms on what deck because it's
all decks right because it's a cruise so
what deck are you staying at and they're
like what deck is that do you think the
Gym's gonna be on I need to go and check
out the Vulcans Pumping Iron because I
guess they they just go on this boat
the ship we shouldn't call it a boat
it's a ship and and they
they just stay in character
like people just are Vulcan for five
days or whatever it is it seems so
awesome I'm so excited they're all
coming in
February 23rd which is a Thursday if
people want to come and have an awesome
Star Trek time
I mean it seems as if they're doing what
Star Wars tried to do with an immersive
Hotel
on a hundredth of the budget yeah yeah
imagination you guys we'll just be in
costume the whole time this is a
Starship now oh it's so much it's so
much fun just like being a voyeur into
that world it's so much fun
uh so yeah you'll definitely if you
don't make it out this month you'll have
to swing down for
um
for Star Trek month
drinks and foods and
Decor all that sort of good stuff oh I
can't wait
um and then my only other the only other
brag I want to throw out there is uh
last I checked my actors Roundtable had
over four and a half million YouTube
views which is pretty crazy I mean it's
a good thing you got like two percent of
things yeah you got points you got
points on it sure sure the amount of
work that went into that thing I I made
about six bucks an hour but um nice but
a lot of people because of you right
nickel of you yeah a lot of people saw
it a lot of people enjoyed it
um and if it helps uh Short Round bring
home some trophies it's I'll take that
as a win
oh hell yeah that is that is my deep and
abiding hope is that kihui Kwan gets to
go on that stage and give the speech
that makes everybody cry
I uh I heard that they were doing and I
can't remember where I heard it Indiana
Jones five reshoots and my My Hope Is
you know Indiana Jones is in New York
Short Round wears a Brooklyn
Giants hat I think or a New York Giants
baseball hat in
Temple of Doom My Hope Is that the
reshoots are
Indie going at the beginning of the
movie he went to some Rando place and I
hope they're reshooting it too
have him go to like some bookstore that
Short Round owns and Short Round sends
him off on his quest
how please please don't make the same
mistake give us Short Round
like in it right now this day and age
how do you not do that the amount of
Goodwill there is you know for that dude
for that role you know for for you know
his Golden Globe speech talking about
how Spielberg gave him his very first
job and look they're both here today
like how do you not
just you know break off a couple of days
and put him in that movie and close that
Circle yeah just let him hug on screen
or something and and then
the movie happens but yeah that would be
now I want it make that happen please
Disney
spare no expense
oh all right do we have questions we've
got questions that people wanted
answered
um I'm gonna I don't I don't I'm not
gonna Venture I guess on this but uh
Phil P said what three movies would you
make mandatory viewing during Black
History Month for schools
three movies mandatory for Black History
Month for kids
I'm going to interpret that as kids and
not uh yeah so let's say
pre-pre-high School Heist maybe
beginning of high school pre-high school
um
I think I would choose
Aquila and the Bee
um which is a fantastic little movie
about a kid who can spell very well
um starring Kiki Palmer in her first
ever movie
um
it's just it's wonderful it's sweet it's
glorious it's joyous it's all it's all
of those things
um
I'm going to avoid
I'm gonna avoid like a straight up
Slavery movie because I don't know how
helpful or instructive that is to black
kids
but I will say
um
Glory I would put on that list it's
slavery adjacent
um but I think it's it's it's very much
about a part of of our history that does
not get talked about nearly enough
um which is the black soldiers who
fought for the the Union
in the in the Civil War I watched Glory
they showed it to us I think my freshman
year of high school maybe
it was either my freshman or junior year
and I just remember being
like Blown Away by how amazing that
movie is
I mean it's it's it's so great it's so
great despite the fact that the movie is
ostensibly about Matthew broderick's
character who is kind of boring as [__]
um you know like that's the the focus is
is slightly off but you know between
Morgan Freeman and Andre Brauer and
Denzel Washington like there's there's
so much power in that cast
um so I think I would do that one
um
and
um there's there's this torn
I'm torn between the documentary about
Motown
um about Berry Gordy and the creation of
the Motown record label and the system
of it
which is you know it is this this
wonderful document about the creation of
possibly the greatest music label that
has ever music labeled
um you know as somebody told me and I
think I mentioned on the podcast when I
mentioned to Kev that I watched a couple
weeks ago the last time that the most
popular thing was also the best thing
um
um and The Whiz I think the whiz is like
this wonderful joyous version I mean
it's the black Wizard of Oz it's it's
you know Diana Ross is Dorothy it's
Michael Jackson as as the the Scarecrow
it's the music is fantastic that you
know the little yellow big road going
through Detroit like it was also a
Motown movie hence the Detroit of it all
um but I think there's there's yes
there's history to be taught but there's
also the as much as you can get of the
totality of that sort of
African-American experience and so
getting something that's just kind of
fun and light and Musical and
entertaining in addition to the history
of Glory in addition to just the kids
story of Akil and the bee
um
I think I think if you had to pick three
those are not bad threes there's a
plenty of others but you know I quite
like the the queen of katwe
um this uh this Disney movie about Chess
about this this you know
and I think I think it was like David or
yellow and Lupita Nyong'o are both in
that movie
um but it's about a chess Prodigy that
comes from one of the poorest places in
Africa who just you know through [__]
Brilliance and Ingenuity and and and
grit rises from uh from the life she led
into the life she wanted so
but there's plenty of those but those
three are not bad start with those three
and if you burn through those come back
there's um there's a few people in chat
throwing out hidden figures which I
thought was awesome yeah I mean it's I
love that movie I was just watching it
the other day I caught it on FX
um
you know the trick is always like
finding the the black stories that are
not history lessons because all too
often it seems like those are the ones
that people want to tell because it's
like oh we found this nugget of History
okay great we can do it then why because
it's space race
or this thing but it's finding like I
would recommend Attack the Block
um which you know I love to death but
I'm not sure if like a nine-year-old
should be watching yeah it's a bit
intense
um all right fine question uh neuromorph
wanted to know what retail store would
you go to for your apocalypse gear up so
we watched Nick Offerman go to Home
Depot
where would you go
I mean you know the Temptation is to say
like you know Home Depot or Lowe's
um I feel like you know Walmart probably
ought to be on that list because then
you can get guns
um in addition to you know plywood and
zip ties and and rotary saws and [__]
um
foreign
I mean I think I think that's
you know I mean there's like a Sam's
Club or a Costco I guess you can get a
decent shotgun at a Costco which is the
weirdest thing to say but I guess you
can but I think I'm gonna stick with
Walmart
I think I think it's it's the giant big
box retailer
um
because then you can get like the
generators that you need you can get the
fridge you can get the guns you can get
food you can get canned goods like all
the stuff that you can't get at a Lowe's
or Home Depot you can then get it at
Walmart in addition to most of the
things you can get from a Lowe's or Home
Depot
um like all the beef jerky all of the
[__] beef jerky all of the clothes
that you could need all of the canned
foods you could need like batteries and
you know yeah yeah I think it's I think
it's probably Walmart
you know and like I mean Lowe's has a
gardening section it's like you can buy
like a fruit tree or two and get seeds
and [__]
but yeah it's the Deep Freeze it's like
well how much meat you got Frozen
foreign
[Music]
if I gotta feel a shitty blue and white
Ford pickup I think that's where I'm
going
uh yeah I think that I think you gotta
lean into Walmart if you're not going to
the hardware store
yeah yeah like you're not gonna get
everything you get at Walmart I mean at
a at a lows but you can get a lot of
those things
the uh last question Anthony placini
Placencia
if you could have any movie or movie
series in history turned into a great
version of a video game what would you
pick
so last of us has been turned into a
great show what movie like we all know
the story of E.T and the Atari
where it was like the worst game of all
time and they just buried all those
copies which did you see some guy went
out I think during the pandemic and he
found him
like he I mean I know there was a
documentary I know that that um
that uh
yeah there was a documentary God I want
to say it's like 10 years old at this
point where they did find one of those
like the burn bits that they put [__]
just mountains of 2600 cartridges in
um
but it would not surprise me that there
was way more than one of those because
I'm sure they printed you know this is
going to be huge it's ET you guys it's
gonna be massive 100
000 cartridges 200 000 cartridges we got
to print them
um okay so what movie slash TV show
would I think would make a great game
that has not already been made into a
game or not a good game not a good game
um you know they they try all the time
but Tron I'm not even entirely sure that
Tron would make for a great game
um and even though it's kind of supposed
to be
um
and I don't know
I mean [__]
Lone Wolf and Cub would actually be a
great game
um
I wonder if ghost of sushima can be like
a sort of test bed the proof of concept
that a sort of Samurai you know
Samurai escorting his son on a quest for
revenge and killing all of the people
who were between him and salvation
um who had something to do with the
death of his wife like it's a clean
story it's samurai action it's got a
cute kid
um that could be fun and it's I mean the
the manga that it's based on is is
phenomenal and it there's like 30
volumes of it so you got nothing but but
Road road maps for that
um
you know I think uh the Warriors could
be cool did they ever make a Warriors
game
um oh maybe
it feels like something that somebody
would have taken a run at at some point
but just like oh we got all these tribes
and they're all going to war you know
let's [__]
you know me it could just be like a
Mortal Kombat kind of game it could just
be like a fighting fighting but mashy
just have a you know
um
that could be super fun
um I mean they keep trying Road Warrior
games like I remember seeing a Mad Max
game around the time the Fury Road came
out
um I don't know if there's any good or
not but it always has like promise of
being good you know like all right
here's our road combat here's our you
know
post-apocalyptic installation combat
here's our hand-to-hand gun stuff
Scavenging for supplies
um
yeah I mean I think I gotta I gotta
and I've never seen I know they they
have made like pinball machines and I'm
sure there are some like mobile games
for Game of Thrones
oh but that also feels like the sort of
thing where like yeah like do that in
that world
you know
that eventually opens up to include like
you know the prequel stuff where you get
to ride [__] dragons and [__]
um
you know there's there's definitely like
an Elder Scrolls version of that
uh that's just the world is huge you can
kind of open world it but there's still
a quest for you to follow and still
goals for you to achieve
um
yeah I think I think I think
if I have to choose not to choose two
I'll choose uh
uh longwoofing Cub or Game of Thrones
I think mine would be and I'm gonna kind
of cheat
and there may be a decent game but
nothing that was just like incredible
would be
um
what one I think like if you just took
Seinfeld and made it open world like you
just go out and explore like the the
show about nothing the game about
nothing
um and it's just like a ton of mini
quests like stupid stuff like you know
Kramer took Jerry's shoes and you got to
get him back but
um I'm surprised they never did like the
Sims Seinfeld Edition yeah right
[Music]
um
but I would love to see I they've never
done a movie or a TV show but I would
love to see they did a comic book which
was G.I Joe Transformers crossover
and I think that that would be an
awesome
video game
where you re like you start on Cybertron
and you come down
you know you follow like Optimus Prime
down to earth and then you team up with
GI Joe and have to fight Cobra and I
think that would be so much so much fun
also
because I used to love playing Rock Band
how much fun would it be to get an
actual like
Guns and Roses video the video game
where you're like Axl Rose young Axel
Rose in like the middle of nowhere
Indiana and you've got to like
steal from shops to get enough money to
get the bus ticket to LA and then all
the stuff that could happen on the bus
and then you get to La and you gotta
form the band and it's kind of like a
like a a game but then you've gotta like
play guitar and sing so like you can
bring out your bust out your rock band
stuff when you get to like auditions and
stuff and then the band breaks up and
like you do this weird thing for some
some levels and then you have to get SLA
like get slash and Duff and everybody
back in the band so like
you know you can pay your rent in Malibu
I I love the like Grand Theft Auto meets
rock band version yeah
I think that would be so fun
you know and I also think that the you
know it's been a long time since they
had a good reason for you to buy giant
kits of cheap plastic instruments at a
premium like I gotta buy the drum set if
I'm gonna play rock band but I gotta buy
a two guitars and a microphone because
we gotta be a band
that'd be fun oh my God the number of
nights that I would like go out with
friends and be like we're all going back
to my house and we all had a little bit
too much to drink we had a little still
had a little bit too much to drink in
the fridge at home and we were just play
rock band and be rock stars all night
long and then wake up and be like why
did we do that
the next morning is so much fun
yeah the the early days of communal
video gaming where uh it was a heady
time where like I'd go to a friend's
house who had a projector set up and we
would play Halo on his like living room
wall and so it was just the four boxes
and like you're just there staring at
the [__] wall for hours to the point
where your eyes don't work right anymore
and you close your eyes and there's
still like life meters and ammo counts
on the bottom and top
did you ever play
um old old games so I did this in high
school so like mid 90s mid to late 90s
commanding conquer
no it's like a tactical strategy game
where you build armies oh I used to risk
and whatever yeah it was the first game
that I ever like
dialed my modem into my friend's house
and we'd stay up all night all summer
destroying each other's armies
there's a there's a game that I still
play
um called uh Civilization Revolution
um and it's it's I mean it's a
civilization game so if you know that
then you understand that you're like
building cities and you're building
armies and you're you know putting
resources to science or gold and you're
all and all that stuff it's it's a deep
like sort of RPG game but it's not it's
all encompassing as civilization proper
is it's sort of like the dumbed down
simpler version of that but it's like
all right choose which coach you want to
be I want to be French I want to be
Russian I want to be from [__] you
know the Aztecs I want to be China Japan
whatever you build your home base you
can build other cities and whatever but
they put a Time cap on it so you start
like 2500 BC and then it ends at like
2095 A.D and it's just it's risk right
it's just all right I build my armies
and I gotta conquer the other guys or I
gotta I gotta build enough science
Ingenuity so that I can launch a rocket
ship to the stars or I can get enough
gold to win an economic win or I can
make enough culture to form the United
Nations like
I like it because it's it's discreet
like it takes about 45 minutes to play a
game there's no real emotional
involvement but it's just kind of
strategy it's just Resource Management
it's just and the world is different
every time it's randomized I wish it was
a multiplayer or people who played on
the multiplayer because the game is now
like 15 years old it just exists now on
the PlayStation network but I love it I
every system I've had I now like found
it on the PS5 and I think I first had it
on the Xbox One
now the Xbox my old school Xbox
um but yeah there's there's sometimes
those games where it's like I don't need
to shoot anybody I don't need to [__]
drive anything I don't need to Pilot
anything
I just want to solve this problem of how
do I dominate everything
somebody Chris uh buchaniac in chat says
a like a John Hughes movie Universe game
which they kind of do in
Ready Player Two the book I think they
make that into a game oh yeah I think
you could get into a lot of trouble that
way though
what's the point of your game a couple
nerds trying to get laid in the 80s yeah
what could go wrong where do you where
do you where'd he come down on rape yeah
because there's a lot of questionable uh
sexual activity going on here
like I was watching uh uh Revenge of the
Nerds it was on like AMC or something I
was like oh I haven't seen this movie in
20 years and I got 20 minutes into this
watch I was like oh god oh this is rough
this is like kind of all kinds of wrong
here
uh but hey there's there's
okay there's there's Anthony Edwards
sure there's [__] wow there's John
Goodman is the coach okay
um is that great yeah
yeah
[Music]
oh the 80s 80s bad judgment all around
like to be able to say that they didn't
know better but I think they knew better
they just didn't care
uh well that was cool that was cool well
thank you thank you chat for giving up
some fun questions
um thank you to Tiffany Smith for
hopping on and talking last of us and
the very top half of our uh of our DC
conversation
thank you as always to uh to the man who
makes this happen without which we would
have no podcast uh JC Banff man
rifenberg and uh and thank uh all of you
your audience for for spending an hour
and a half with me
um as I whack silly
um cool and fun [__] thank you to the
good folks in Native for making it so
that we can do this
um on an irregular basis
um and I'm not sure when we'll be back
but hopefully
um there will be another person
um next to me or on the opposite box of
me wherever the boxes are
um and I can go back to bamping in and
being my little and you can Banff in if
the bath makes you happier
then we'll benefit just like that
um but yes thank you this has been
another episode of black man beyond
um stay tuned same black Time same black
Channel
um smodcast.com I who have been Mark
Bernard sorry missed that part
um but yes mycast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith goodnight everybody drive
safe wherever you're driving to
um stay warm or cool uh and we'll see
you soon
[Music]
peace
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]